continuing uh that storm and those
dangerous conditions are having a ripple
effect right here in las vegas our
bianca holmen live with more on flights
may be canceled already in and out of
harry reid airport bianca that's exactly
right this major storm expected to bring
heavy snow as you've seen freezing rain
terrible conditions for flights
emergency declarations have prompted
flight cancellations flight aware it's a
website that reports on canceled flights
and delayed flights around the country 4
000 they're reporting 4 000 flights are
grounded in and out of the u.s and about
320 are delayed and that number
continues to grow
you may remember back in december and
january severe weather and staff
shortages contribute to 50 000 canceled
trips on wednesday afternoon more than
40 flights were either departing or
arriving were canceled out of harry reid
international airport and many of them
were from southwest frontier and spirit
airlines so this morning as of right now
we just checked they're about 110
canceled arrivals and departures out of
harry reid international airport so if
you're expecting family or friends
coming in for the big sports weekend you
might they may be delayed one or two
days so be sure to check on those flight
apps check the website frequently even
if you plan on flying out later on today
those flights are still going to be
impacted by this the severe storm that's
happening across the country bianca
holman live local now double and triple
check bianca thank you